Hey guys, Pete here. Today I'm picking up
on my two-part timeline video for
Netflix's Dark. In part one I covered
the story in chronological order up
until the year 1987 in this video we'll
cover everything that's happened through
season 2 from 2019 through 2053. I'll
put a link at the top for the part 1
video if you want to watch them in order
but really it's up to you. if you haven't
watched season 2 yet this will contain
massive SPOILERS so you don't want to
watch this video before you watch the
actual season. there's a lot to cover
here so let's jump right in. season 2 of
Dark is set up to be in chronological
order in the days leading up to the
apocalypse in 2020 except for episode
number 6 which is where we start. that
episode takes place on June 20th the day
before Michael commits suicide on June
20th 2019. the day starts with the
original Jonas having breakfast with
Michael we see Jonas grab the yellow
rain jacket and Michael has a deja vu
moment. after that young Jonas, Magnus,
Martha, and Bartosz go to the lake. we find
out that Katharina and Ulrich are
throwing their 25th wedding anniversary
party Hannah asked Michael to go with
her but he declines younger Jonas finds
the st. Christopher medallion in the
sand and then he leaves because he has
to go see his grandmother at that point
younger Jonas from the future arrives
from 1921 and he ends up kissing Martha
at the beach younger Magnus sees younger
Franziska skinny-dipping at the lake and
that's where he starts to have feelings
for her back at the Nielsen's we see
that Mikkel has rubella so they have to
take him to the doctor
on the way they stop at Hannah's house
and Mikkel sees adult Michael and it's a
weird situation where Mikkel ends up
running away adult Aleksander Tiedemann
sees an article about the unsolved
Marburg murders later that day he
contacts Woller for help in finding
something for him on the phone original
young Jonas goes to the anniversary
party with his mom Hannah Marta gives
him the st. Christopher medallion
necklace that she made for him after
that Jonas and Marta have sex together
for the first time at the party Ulrich
and Hannah get together and some people
think that this is when their
affair starts and other people think it
may have happened before that or it
started before that it's not really
clear future younger Jonas finds Michael
at the house he pleads with him not to
kill himself and he shows him the
suicide letter Michael reveals to Jonas
that it was a future version of him that
actually took him through the passage
back to 1986 on the night that he
originally disappeared at that point
older Claudia comes in she interrupts
them and tells Jonas he must go against
Adam which is himself obviously and that
she's actually seen a world where Jonas
doesn't exist and it's not what Jonas
right now expects she goes on to say
that they all have to make sacrifices
and that would include Michael and that
he needs to take his own life
later Michael does write the suicide
letter teen Jonas goes to the caves and
this is the beginning of where they
spent their year together where he was
being trained he goes back to 1986 on
June 21st
Michael does hang himself and leaves
behind the letter with instructions that
it shouldn't be read until November 4th
at 10:13 p.m. at some point after that
happens
Jonas goes and spends 2 months in a
psychiatric facility while everyone else
thinks he just went to France thanks to
Bartosz telling them that fast forward
to October 22nd that's the day that Erik
goes missing and we know that he was
kidnapped by adult Helge fast forward
again to November 4th and we see Helga
arrived from 1986 again we get the idea
that he's going back and forth younger
Jonas goes back to school for the first
time and while he's there he finds out
that Martha and Bartosz are dating now
older inés reads the letter from Michael
after 10:13 p.m. that evening at the
same time Jonas, Martha, Bartosz, Magnus,
Mikkel, and Franziska go to the caves
this is where the whole thing goes down
Mikkel goes missing he ends up being
transported through the caves after
being shown the way by a future version
of younger Jonas of course he's with one
Jonas they get split up and the other
one swoops in and takes him through the
cave similar to the situation we saw
where
the Jonas switch at the beach and the
second one is the one that gives Martha
the kiss adult Regina also finds out
that the hotel is going to be forced to
close down due to not making enough
money and they're having some kind of
financial trouble Peter sees Mads body
appear in the bunker and then he calls
Tronte and they have to take care of it
they find this out because owner Claudia
shows up and tells them to get rid of
the body and gives them the
leather-bound notebook the next day on
November 5th Mads body is found in the
forest Charlotte and Ulrich realized
it's not Mikkel but they don't know who
it is at this point on the same day
Ulrich finds the door to the power plant
in the caves at the same time Stranger
aged or adult Jonas shows up in windin
and he goes and gets a room at Regina's
hotel we see Helga emerge from the caves
again on this day as well younger Jonas
finds Michael's map of the caves in his
studio and later in that same day
Aleksander orders the radioactive waste
barrels to be dug up and moved somewhere
else on november 6th younger Jonas
starts exploring the caves now that he
has the map Charlotte finds the bunker
as she's looking into the case of
Mikkel's disappearance and Mads body
showing up younger Elizabeth meets adult
Noah it happens off screen but she
returns home with a pocket watch that he
gave her to give to Charlotte
the next day November 7th Yasin is
kidnapped by Helge Jonas and Martha share
a kiss backstage after her play when he
blew off Barosz to go see it when he
gets back home he receives the package
from older Jonas and he reads his
father's letter learning that Michael's
true identity is that he was Mikkel who
traveled back on November 8th adult
Regina is diagnosed with breast cancer
as he's going through the evidence
Ulrich realizes the dead boy from the
forest is actually his brother Mads from
1986 the next day on November 9th Ulrich
goes and confronts older Helge for the
first time at the hospital this leads
Charlotte to suspending him from the
case giving him some time off more or
less Katharina then tell
him that she knows about the affair with
Hannah and on the same day older Jana
tells Ulrich that she saw Helge in 2019
she remembers him from the past and says
that he hasn't aged after that Ulrich
follows older Helge into the caves he
sees in walking so he follows along ends
up in the caves younger Jonas arrives
back from 1986 two days later on
November 11th oder Claudia visits Bartosz
and asked him to give Regina a photo of
the two of them from 1986 Hannah uses
the passport from Boris Niewald to
blackmail Aleksander she wants him to
destroy Ulrich's life Regina finally
goes into the hotel room that older
Jonas had rented and she sees all the
files and paperwork related to the time
travel later that night Bartosz
agrees to work with Noah to help Noah
older Jonas takes some of the
radioactive waste the stuff that fuels
the time machine out of the barrels in
the truck and then later Jonas tells
Martha that they can't be together it
isn't going to work on November 12th
younger Jonas confronts his grandmother
Ines about Michael Mikkel's true
identity he then has a fight with
Bartosz outside the school
Charlotte is digging through some
information and she runs into Ulrich's
photo in a newspaper from 1953 Noah
gives Bartosz the notebook and he warns
him to never trust Claudia Charlotte
runs into Peter in the bunker then the
time portal opens over wenden we see all
the different effects on the electricity
and people are experiencing it but
nothing actually happens of note in 2019
and that is the last thing that happens
in that year
moving on to 2020 On June 21st Clausen
takes over the missing persons case and
later we find out that he actually
requested the position Katharina is
exploring the caves she's trying to
figure out where Ulrich went we see
Bartosz and Martha meet under the bridge
to break up they decide not to see each
other anymore
Hannah is about to kill herself but then
older
Jonas the stranger shows up that puts
an end to that plan Martha finds all
of Ulrich's police files in Mickle's room and she
shows them to Magnus younger Elisabeth
finds a photo of Noah in an old book in
H.G. Tannhaus' shop she explains to Peter
that that's Noah in the photo Woller
brings the radioactive waste back to the
power plant Aleksander has the waist
covered in concrete where it stays until
a little bit later
On June 22nd Clausen and Charlotte
re-interview Regina during that she
tells them about older Jonas about him
staying at the hotel gives them all the
papers that were in the hotel room older
Jonas shows handed the time machine and
he ends up taking her back to 1987 two
days later on June 24th middle Claudia
the one from 1986 actually arrives and
learns that Regina has cancer after that
she goes to the power plant looking for
herself we think but she learns that
Aleksander is actually now running it
Claudia goes to the library after that
looks herself up on Google she learns
about her own disappearance in 1987 and
after that she returns
Charlotte calls in sick doesn't go to
work and then she goes through all the
time-travel files that she has
everything that's at Tannhaus' shop
older Jonas finds his gun right after
that Hannah has Charlotte come over to
meet Jonas Charlotte shows him the
picture of Noah from 1921 and he tells
them about the travelers sick Mundus
Charlotte takes Hannah and Jonas to the
bunker and shows them all the files that
she's collected where she now has them
up on the wall Peter explains that older
Claudia told them everything to do we
see that the notebooks there they decide
to tell Katharina so Charlotte goes and
picks her up and brings her to the
bunker they explained the whole
situation but Katharina doesn't believe
them Katarina goes back to the school
though looks up the records for Michael
and she finds the picture where she sees
Mikkel in the class photo and finally
believes everything Magnus Martha
Francisca and younger Elisabeth go to
the caves where they run into bartosh
they end up leaving him there tied up
they take the Machine from him but
they're not sure what it is we see
closet and ball or interview
xander and we learned that he's asking
all these questions about his past not
really about the missing people right
now because she's with the other people
Hannah also misses her interview
appointment with Claussen on June 25th
older Jonas goes to Martha's bedroom and
leaves the st. Christopher necklace for
her Hannah tells Katarina about older
Jonas' time machine and we see Klaus
and finally interview Hannah he ends up
showing her a drawing of older stranger
aged Jonas the kids all go back into the
caves to get answers from Bartosz and
finally when they're leaving he tells
them it's a time machine to show them
how it works he takes them the 1987 at
the bunker older Jonas tell Charlotte
about Noah and how Claudia was using
them all to further her own agenda noah
comes to meet Charlotte he tells her
that he's her father and that he plans
on killing Adam so that everyone not
just the ones that are gonna be in the
bunker will survive the coming
apocalypse and we see the gang all
returned back from 1987 after they did
their time travel after that Martha
returns to her room and she finds the
necklace that older Jonas left there for
her on June 26 Hannah steals older
Jonas's time machine and leaves for 1954
Charlotte tells Peter about Noah and the
coming apocalypse Claussen arrests
Aleksander for identity theft
Clausen reveals that his brother
Alexander Kohler disappeared in 1986 and
that's whose identity alexander stole
Claussen said he found out that he had
to go to Winden because someone had sent
him a letter
Marthameets older Jonas he tells her
who he really is
Katharina shows up after that and reveals
that Jonas is her nephew because Mikkel
and Michael were the same person and
Katarina takes Mars away he tells them
that Hannah took the time machine but
Martha says that Magnus has a time
machine as well Magnus then brings a
time machine to Martha and Katarina on
June 27th Bartosz tells Regina that
Claudia isn't dead and visited last fall
he gives her the photo of her and
Claudia from 1986 older Jonas tells
Martha that she needs to go to the
bunker because he can't watch her
again she refuses so he pulls the gun
and he forces her into the bunker
Katarina finds the map of the cave and
the flashlight in Jonas's room younger
Jonas and middle Claudia arrived from
1987 he tells Claudia to bring the time
machine to the bunker Claudia leaves and
goes and gets Regina and takes her with
her to the bunker younger noJonas arrives
from 1921 and he gives older Jonas a
letter from Marta saying he must say
Bartosz Magnus Franziska and Noah so
that Martha will live and the prophecy
will be fulfilled Waller tells Charlotte
about helping Aleksander bury the
radioactive waste at the power plant and
Charlotte then tells him everything
that's going on Clausen gets a search
warrant for the power plant and insists
on checking the old reactor room when
they pass it Peter takes younger
Elisabeth into the bunker Martha leaves
the bunker and returns to the Kahnwald
house where she finds younger Jonas they
end up having a kiss Adam then arrives
from 1921 he ends up killing Martha to
ensure that younger Jonas will
eventually turn into him Katharina heads
into the caves and she opens up the
passage Claussen discovers the barrels
under the concrete and orders them open
despite Charlotte protesting that they
shouldn't do that in that process the
god particle is created and a wormhole
between 2020 and 2053 opens up
allowing Charlotte to make contact with
older Elisabeth older Jonas finds Bartosz
Magnus and Francisca and uses the time
machine to take them away we don't know
which year but we know they made it out
of there
and back at the Kahnwald house alternate
Martha or other-world Martha arrives and
uses a new time-traveling device to save
young Jonas take him to safety
and potentially to an alternate universe
that is the last thing we see in 2020 we
go to 2052 at the end of season one we
see younger Jonas arrive after touching
Helge in the wormhole and we see
Silja take him into custody that's
really the only thing we see in 2052
for sure there is this scene of Claudia
outside whenever
event is happening that would put that
in 2052 if she was in the future but
we can't say for sure it looks similar
but we can't say for sure in 2053 we
see that Jonas has been there for a
while he's doing stuff he's trying to
figure out how to get out of there we
see him in the bunker which we saw
Claudia in with the string wall with the
photos we see him moving through town
forest dates go on June 21st we know
that Elisabeth executes the two French
men for entering the dead zone on that
same day younger Jonas discovers the god
particle is still in the power plant
ruins on the next day he's caught going
back into the dead zone and is sentenced
to death by older Elisabeth he needed to
get that fuel he gets it takes it inside
and then he gets caught on that same day
he's hanged but older Elisabeth ends up
shooting the rope and he doesn't
actually die they lock him up then later
Silja breaks him out asked him who he is
demands that he show her what's actually
going on inside the dead zone he takes
her shows her the god particle he
prepares it for travel and then he goes
through the portal later on we see her
leave and older Elisabeth catches her
and ask her what she's doing they have a
confrontation later on June 27th this is
the date that the prophecy says that the
passage will open up and everyone will
be led into paradise we see older
Elisabeth dig up a box of her personal
belongings things that she had hidden
that she's kept from the past and then
we see her go into the power plant the
wormhole opens she makes contact with
Charlotte who is her mother and also her
daughter and we don't know what happens
after that that would be everything we
see in the current timeline so yeah that
is everything that we see in
chronological order while it's a ton of
stuff there's obviously a lot of stuff
left out that we're not going to be able
to find out about until season 3 and
it's a really interesting show the
deeper that they go the more you realize
that there's all these bootstrap
paradoxes that affect each other when I
was doing this video this time I was
wondering if she could have actually
even killed Jonas I mean she really
couldn't have right because he's existed
at an older age so when she shoots the
rope he actually was never gonna die
anyway sort of in the way
that Helge didn't die when Ulrich bashed
him in the head with the rock so many
times let me know in the comments what
you think about the timeline what you
think about dark in general what you
want to see in season 3 anything that's
on your mind about dark but that's all I
got for today I will be doing some other
dark videos in the next coming days so
make sure you subscribe give this video
a like if you enjoyed it thanks for
watching guys I will talk to you soon